hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
automation of organoid acids requiring a
3d matrix with dragonfly
discovery i'm susie valdez of labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by spt lab tech
to learn more visit them at
sptlabtech.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers
hilary sherman
a senior application scientist at
corning life sciences
and ann hammerstein from spt
lab tech welcome both of you and
you may now begin your presentation
thank you for this uh kind introduction
so thank you everyone for joining us
today
uh we're delighted to bring this webinar
to you today
um today's work has really been uh
carried out by two wonderful people
hillary from uh
corning who's uh speaking and presenting
today
as well as my colleague holly hung who's
one of our field application scientists
um today in terms of the structure of
today's talk
um i will begin by giving you a brief
introduction
around uh some of the challenges of
setting up 3d
cell cultures using automation and i'll
also
bring you a brief overview of some of
the instruments
that can be used for this process and in
particular the dragonfly discovery
that has been used for the case study
that hillary will present
uh hillary's case study is called
intestinal fossil-induced dwelling assay
and and she will go into some technical
details as well as
scientific results of this case study
and we will conclude today's
webinar with um some questions and
answers and as
suzie has explained please keep fielding
them as we go along
so we have lots of time to go through
them at the end of this presentation
so when we think about setting up 3d
cell
cultures there's a number of challenges
in particular with regards to automating
this process
when we talk to our customers we're
hearing
about a desire to increase the
throughput of these assays
but that is really limited by the supply
of cells and oftentimes precious
reagents there's only so much material
available
with which we can set up these assays
and
the materials themselves can be very
tricky to handle
um materials like corning's matrigel
require
tight temperature control to pipette
accurately
and generally the material is is quite
variable there's
biological variants within there but
there's an
added challenge of ensuring there's high
homogeneity when using automation to set
up these assays
lots of our customers are also telling
us you know they would like to use the
strongest possible biological model but
of course that comes at a cost
so is there an opportunity to perhaps
miniaturize and save reagents
and enable more assays from a finite
amount of material
i want to tell you first of all how some
of our instruments are well placed to
address these challenges
so if we uh take a quick look at the
next slide
at spt lab tech we um
use positive displacement pipetting and
dispensing
as as the basis of our technology and
we can use this uh either with low
volume liquid handling as on the left
this is our mosquito liquid handler
setting down droplets
of liquid transferring from one plate to
another
and the key with positive displacement
is really that the liquid is in direct
contact with a piston
that sits either inside the pipette
barrel as you can see on the left hand
side
or a dispensed syringe as you can see on
the right hand side
and we when we transfer liquids it's
really the movement of that piston
directly
on the liquid that moves the liquid
there is no
air cushion involved there's no system
fluid there's
no lines anything like that it's really
the direct transfer of the liquid
and the big advantage of using this
method is that it's suitable for all
liquid classes so
from very volatile things like 80
ethanol
up to very viscous materials like 80
glycerol
but also jelly-like materials like
corning's matrigel
and this method of pipetting and
dispensing is extremely
accurate even at the smallest volumes
um today's presentation focuses on
dispensing using our dragonfly discovery
instrument
and and if we take a look at the next
slide
here we go this is our our dragonfly
sorry just there we go
this is our dragonfly discovery reagent
dispenser
so this is a small benchtop unit that
comes with a choice of either three
six or ten dispense heads that you can
see dispensing on the video on the right
hand side
it is a non-contact reagent dispenser so
it is not reliant on perpetual
at all um liquid is transferred directly
from these
stationary tips onto the plate below
and these tips have a big dynamic range
starting at just 200 nanoliters right up
to 4ml
so with that it's possible to really
drive down
dispense volumes quite aggressively uh
miniaturize
assays and thereby save pressure cells
or reagents and as i said this is based
on positive displacement
uh so it is truly liquid class agnostic
we do not have to specify the type of
liquid that we do dispense
you can also see that this descent is
very fast so
using six uh tips for example we can
fill a
384 well plate in under 30 seconds
if you wanted to really minimize dead
volumes you could
fill a 384 well plate in around two
minutes
and this method of liquid dispensing
delivers outstanding accuracy
at low volumes um we can fill any type
of plate
starting from 96 or plates right up to
15 36 more plates so
we we're compatible with most scales of
assay but if i just
jump to the next slide
there we go just by word of reference we
won't be talking very much about the
mosquito liquid handler today but we
have some customers
using this instrument for 3d cell
culture applications
that require contact uh dispensing or
pipetting
the mosquito works a little bit
different to the dragonfly discovery
it's a pipette
uh tip based system and each instrument
has a reel of pet tips on the top
you can see a single tip on the right so
that's a polypropylene barrel
that is fitted with a single stainless
steel piston on the inside
and it's the movement up and down of
that piston inside the barrel
that moves and transfers liquids so
mosquito is a liquid handler so that
really allows it to transfer liquids
from one plate
onto another using a contact dispense
it comes this instrument in a range of
models there's a
low volume version that can uh pipet
between 25 nanoliters
right up to 1.25 microliters
or a high volume version that goes from
500 nanoliters
up to 5 microliters the mosquito
lv and mosquito hv are multi-channel
instruments
that pipette column by column either
using 8 or 16 channels
we also have an option of a single
channel instrument that allows cherry
picking
and that's available in either the high
or the lower volume
configuration hillary
will show you some videos um of matrigel
dispensing uh shortly but just to give a
flavor of what we can do
the first video that's playing here
shows you a single tip
dispensing 200 nanoliters of 0.7
major gel into a 384 well plate and this
is in real time
and probably all you can see is a little
air bubble that seems to be forming
at the end of the dispense that's just a
little suck-back motion to ensure that
that nitrogen
um dispenses accurately and cleanly into
this plate
um but the process is extremely fast is
extremely clean
we are able to dispense more
concentrated solutions of matrigel than
this and we can talk about what's
possible in the question and answers at
the end
obviously when dispensing reagents like
matrigel
temperature control is extremely
important so this right hand side video
just shows you we have this
passive cooling block that can be put
into the freezer prior to setting up the
experiment
the agent reservoir is then placed on
top of that
and we can quickly add the matrigel
solution into this reservoir
and that type of setup provides passive
cooling for a period of time
and we're also working on a passive
cooling element that wraps around the
syringe so once that matrigel has been
aspirated
it can also stay cool in the
in the syringe body of course
when we're working uh with cells
and pressure cells often times with
these 3d assays
it's extremely important to ensure that
there is
no contamination between cell lines um
that there's no carry over anything like
that
so all of our instruments work with
single use
high quality consumables we control
the production and the supply of these
so we are confident that we can
deliver them for some labs getting hold
of the pet tips is a real issue right
now
so that does not affect us and we are of
course uh
very certain of the quality of the
material that we supply
uh syringes are made from high quality
polypropylene
and the reservoirs from hdpe so that
three to minimize
any passive absorption of materials onto
the plastic
and we can use a single um
[Music]
syringe type to address the full uh
dispense volume range so unlike a
petting system
perhaps where you're used to having your
yellow tip and your blue tip or
or some systems where you have to change
the type of source plate that you can
use
that is not the case here that single
clip can really address the full
dispensed range
that is accessible to the instrument um
for very large reagent supplies if
someone is really looking at setting up
very high throughput assays
on the bottom right you can see a pumped
valve
that's a system that allows us to
increase the reagent supply move away
from the open cup reservoirs
in this case we put a bottle next to the
instrument that is fed via peristaltic
tubing
and the syringe the dragonfly syringe
can then take the required amount of
material
from that valve uh meanwhile the reagent
van continues circulation so nothing
can settle um if you've
got any questions about the instrument
i'll be happy to answer them at the end
that is my very brief introduction of
the dragonfly
instrument done with that um
i would like to thank you for this part
of the presentation and hand over to
hillary
hillary over to you please
great thanks so much anne for setting us
up for
the next few slides okay
so before we dive into the actual
application i just want to give a little
bit of a background
on organoid cell culture in general
so to start with there's still some
debate as to
what is truly defined as an organoid
versus a spirit
um but i've compiled here a list of of
what i believe are some of the more
commonly accepted criteria
so spheroids in general are more
simplistic
3d structures that arise mostly from
cell lines
or primary cells organized on the other
hand
are generated from stem or progenitor
cells
and can thus differentiate into multiple
cell types
that are much more reflective of the
organ itself
a spheroid would require multiple cell
types to be added in order to have this
level of complexity
additionally the organized self
organizes using cues from the ecm around
it
such as ecms like the corning matrigel
matrix
and this allows for cells to be
organized in a more similar
fashion to how they would be in vivo
with a spheroid the 3d structure
typically does not self-organize
so now that we have a better idea of
what an arkanoid is let's talk about
why organites are such a valuable model
first and foremost they better resemble
the complexity of the actual tissue
they're modeling
when taken from a patient biopsy they're
able to maintain the genetic diversity
of the tissue source
and this is really important for
understanding tissue complexity and
diversity
as well as for the potential to use
organoids for personalized medicine
in the case of organoids generated from
ipsc or esc
organize help us to better understand
organoid development
organ development and disease
progression as we get a peek into how
the organ
actually develops additionally
organized can be maintained in culture
for long periods of time
without genotypic changes also organic
cultures can be initiated from a small
amount of
input material this can be ipsc or a
biopsy from
stem cells even those found in urine and
and finally organoids can be modified
via crispr
or other methods more traditionally used
for two-dimensional cell culture
so how do you actually make an organoid
as i mentioned in the previous slide
organoids are derived from stem or
progenitor cells
and the method used to generate an
organoid will depend on the type of
organoid and its purpose
adult stem cell derived organoids are
ideal for personalized medicine
or for making organoid libraries and
they're initiated from taking a biopsy
that will contain stem cells
such as an intestinal or lung biopsy
these biopsies are then minced or
digested and the cells themselves are
embedded in an ecm such as major gel
matrix
over the course of a week or two
organoids will actually start to become
visible within the ecm
for organoid models where biopsies are
actually not possible
or where a positive and negative control
organoid from the same patient might be
desired
it might make more sense to generate
organoids from pluripotent stem cells
here organoids are derived from ipsc or
ef cells collected from
you know typical methods of generating
those cells
and the pluripotent stem cells are then
differentiated towards the organoid of
interest
via several stages of media exchanges
over what typically takes multiple weeks
the final differentiation step is where
the 3d structures are actually embedded
in matrigel
in order to generate the organoids
because of the differentiation process
involved with pse
derived organoids the resulting organoid
can form
with more of the cells associated with
the in vivo environment
such as a mesenchymal niche with
intestinal cells
these associated cells may or may not be
present with
adult stem cell derived organoids
i mentioned that ecm such as matrigel
are required for organoid culture
and for those of you who have not worked
with matrigel matrix before
it's a basement membrane prep that's
somewhat of a viscous liquid when it's
cold
and it polymerizes to form a gel as it
warms up
and the unique temperature properties of
major gel allow for fully encapsulating
cells
or creating complex structures but it
can also make it a bit tricky to work
with
like ann alluded to one of the most
important considerations when working
with nitrogen
is to keep everything cold so pre-chill
everything that will come in contact
with the matrigel
so that it doesn't start to prolimer
polymerize prematurely
that means that every tip every plate
every what reservoir
needs to be pre-chilled in order to keep
the matrigel nice and cold
in the case of using the dragonfly
discovery that meant
pre-chilling the syringe based tips and
also using a cold block
in order to keep the reagent reservoir
nice and cold
in terms of matrigel matrix there are
different formulations
depending on the application since we're
working with intestinal organize
we use matrigel for organoid culture
this particular formulation has been
optimized to have a protein
concentration range that's much more
specific for organoid cell culture
additionally each lot is tested in order
to be able to form
and maintain a stable dome which is one
of the more commonly used methods for
organoid culture
and i'll describe that in the next slide
so as i mentioned um you know dome
culture is one of the more common
methods for culturing organized
but there are lots of other methods that
are used as well
and the method you choose will be
dependent on the the type of application
so the image and the schematic on the
left
demonstrate what's referred to as an
embedded culture
this is where the cells are mixed with
the ecm prior to dispensing
and typically the well is fully
fully full of the matrigel and and
cell suspension the result is a gel in
which the 3d structures will form
throughout the gel
and you can see that in the image some
of the structures are in focus
while other structures are out of focus
and that's because the structures are
actually at different focal heights
now this is an easy way to create 3d
structures for
a homogeneous assay or if you're just
trying to bulk produce spirits
but if you want to do imaging this
method is not really ideal
because it would result in really long
scan times
due to the instrument having to focus on
so many different focal planes
sandwich method in the middle is better
suited to imaging assays as you can see
from the image in the cartoon
the cells are much more in focus and
sitting in
in a more singular uniform plane
and this is because the matrigel is
added to the plate and allowed to
polymerize
before the cells are then added on top
and then finally the last method shown
all the way to the right
demonstrates what i am referring to with
the dome culture
here small droplets of matrigel and
cells are mixed together and dispensed
into
the microplate creating three to ten
microliter domes in size
and the result is an embedded culture
but in a much
narrower focal plane that also doesn't
require a lot of material to work with
and so this is the method that i'm going
to focus on for the rest of the
presentation
because it's the method that we used in
our actual
application
all right so now that we have some
backgrounds let's actually talk about
the organized application
that holly and i automated with the
dragonfly discovery
so the model that we chose to automate
is a forskolin-induced swelling assay
for studying
cystic fibrosis cystic fibrosis is a
devastating disease in which mutations
in the cftr
gene result in poor regulation of
chloride ions
into and out of the cells and this
ultimately causes poor regulation of
fluids in the cells
that contain these cftr channels such as
the lungs and the intestine
individuals with cystic fibrosis produce
abnormal amounts of mucus
sweat saliva tears and digestive enzymes
the forskolin induced swelling assay
that we're going to talk about
is actually one of the first examples of
a functional assay that could be
accomplished with organized so it's a
really important
application and it was found that
intestinal biopsies could actually be
used to grow
organoids as a model to study cystic
fibrosis
and as well as cftr function and
potential treatments for this disease
so the assay that was developed starts
with making three to five microliter
droplets or domes
of matrigel and intestinal organized
onto plates
and then exposing them to compounds in
order to measure the fluid transport
so the image that you're looking on the
left is a typical dome
containing many healthy intestinal
organized so you can see those
sort of empty balloon looking structures
each one of those
is an intestinal organoid
so for maintenance of culture and scale
up i typically make domes
multiple domes per well in a multiple
well plates such as a 24 wheel plate
and you can see a representative image
exampling that on the right where you
see multiple
domes or multiple droplets in each well
okay so i'm hoping these videos are
going to work here um
it looks like they're working on my
screen so for the actual
functional assay the organizer exposed
to forskolin to initiate a swelling
response and the videos that you're
looking at here
correspond with fluorescently stained
intestinal organoids that have been
stimulated with forskolin
now the healthy organoids are on the
left and what hopefully you can see
is that the organoids themselves
increase in
size over time okay and so this is what
would be more of a typical response
for a healthy organoid that has been
stimulated with force going
now the image on the right are cystic
fibrosis organized
and hopefully what you can see there is
that the organized themselves are not
really increasing
in size over time and that's because of
mutations of the cftr gene
so this change in organized size can
then
actually be quantified with a high
content imager
or some other kind of image analysis
software such as
image j now these domes are typically
made by hand pipe heading
which as you can probably imagine is not
really ideal for high-throughput
applications as it's fairly
labor-intensive
and can result in a high degree of
variability
okay so um here's the overall workflow
that we followed for our assay
first the organoids are scaled up in
order to actually have enough for the
assay so this was done in 24
well microplate
and um then the organoids are actually
broken up into smaller pieces by
forcefully pipetting with a small
pipette tip
or a 20 gauge needle and then the
organoid pieces are then
actually mixed with matrigel to a final
concentration between
4.5 and 5.5 migs per ml
and then they're dispensed with the
dragonfly discovery
the domes dispensed were at three
microliters in size
and were distributed to each well of a
pre-warmed
96 well plate for dome assays we
actually pre-warm the plate to 37
degrees before dispensing
so that the dome sets up quickly after
overnight culture we then use the
dragonfly discovery to add calcium am
to fluorescently label the organize in
order to make the imaging easier
after about 30 minutes the medium is
then removed and the dragonfly was used
to add media with or without compounds
as well as our forskolin for stimulation
and the organizers were then
continuously imaged every 10 minutes for
60 minutes
in order to monitor the swelling
okay so currently there are as i
mentioned limited tools for accurately
dispensing
small droplets of mature gel and
organoids precisely into the center of
microplate wells
for high throughput applications it's
really important that the domes are
consistent in size
and location within each well
since this is an imaging assay the scan
times would be drastically increased if
the domes are not consistently placed in
each well
and so the dragonfly discovery had no
problem dispensing the matrigel droplets
as it uses a syringe based tip that
works extremely well for viscous
solutions
we dispensed a single three microliter
droplet into the center of each well of
a 96 wall microplate
we also had really good success with
dispensing into 384 well microplates
which i'm hoping you guys are watching
with the video on the screen here
so what you're seeing here is a 96 well
plate with a single three microliter
droplet of human intestinal organized
dispensed into each well by the
dragonfly discovery
after 24 hours organoids were stained
with cows and am
and imaged using our high content imager
the image on the right is
one well zoomed in close so that you can
actually make out the individual
organoids
you can see that one field of view was
able to capture the same domes
which are consistent in size shape and
location and the fact that
you can use one field of view with your
image
imager to capture the organized dome and
that is in the same place
in every well every time makes for much
faster scanning which is
extremely important for high throughput
applications
so before actually running our assay we
first wanted to confirm that we could
consistently dispense the same number of
organoids across a 96 well plate
organized pieces are much heavier than
single cells
so we were concerned that we might be
getting some settling which could
increase the variability
in our assay the data here shows that we
achieved cvs of less than 18
for each of three plates tested so this
gave us confidence that we could
dispense the same number of organoids in
each well
across the plate and wouldn't have any
settling that could
impact our assay
so one of the aspects that makes cystic
fibrosis so
difficult to treat is the fact that
there are many
possible mutations of the cftr gene that
can result in cystic fibrosis of varying
severity
so this also means that there's not
currently a single treatment that will
work for everyone
so here we're comparing multiple drugs
or combinations of drugs
in order to see the impact on organized
swelling
you're looking at a representative dome
at time
0 and times 60 minutes after forced glen
stimulation
using various compounds you may be able
to visually see the increased swelling
with the healthy organoids
at time 60 versus time zero but the
other images might be a little harder to
assess by eye
which is why we use imaging software in
order to actually do this analysis
so here are the results from the actual
high content analysis
of the organoids you can see that the cf
swelling response
in blue is much lower than that of the
healthy control
additionally the cf organized treated
with drug vx-809
had a somewhat increased response so a
little bit of improved swelling
but still not not as much as what a
typical healthy response should look
like
the the gray line is drug vx-770
which actually elicited a very large
improvement in the swelling response
and then finally the combination of the
two drugs which is often the case
for cystic fibrosis patients resulted
in the largest response for this
particular organized line
so one of the things that this assay
demonstrates is is really
the merit of a personalized approach in
order to find the best outcome
for a patient
so i just want to thank you so much for
your time today
and at this point we'd be happy to take
any questions that you might have
thank you
and thank you so much ann and hillary
for that informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you want
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's get started because we have
some great questions already coming in
our first question is you mentioned
that you have tried dispensing domes
into 384 well plates what
volume did you use per well
yeah so i can take that one um so i
think what we ultimately
decided worked pretty well was around
250
um nanoliters um
to make a dome that would stand tall
enough give us enough of
a of a sample to image and and not touch
the edges
of the 3d4 well
thank you so much and how long does it
take
to dispense in all 96 wells
gosh it was really fast it was
definitely less than
a minute um and i don't know if you have
anything to add there
um it will take around about a minute it
always depends
of course how many of the uh dispense
heads
are used simultaneously but i think in
that single
dispense head setup that you describe
about a minute sounds
sounds right using multiple heads
um it will be even faster than that but
i think that would only be applicable
in in very high throughput scenarios
where you really want to fill multiple
plates very very rapidly
thank you thank you so much and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in now how long did the domes
polymerize for before adding medium
yeah that's a great question and a
really good point
that when you run these assays um you do
have to let the dome fully polymerize
before you come back
and add cell culture media um so i would
say
for for domes that are three microliters
in size
15 minutes is is plenty of time to allow
that
full polymerization to occur
thank you so much what is the dead
volume
of the reservoir you used
so i can probably answer this one um so
for
applications such as 3d cell cultures
using
matrigel we recommend the use of a low
dead volume reservoir and that carries a
dead volume of just
30 microliters uh we obviously recognize
that
these assays use uh very precious
reagents and cells
you know if it's patient-derived cells
uh as in
these models then we can't afford to
waste any in
tubing um so with positive displacement
we can aspirate almost all of the
material out of this loaded volume
reservoir and dispense all of that into
the plate
so the dead volume that we carry is
around 30 microliters
and that is simply required to ensure
that there's
good wetting of the plunger that sits
inside the syringe
so there's no air bubbles or so on to
ensure the dispense accuracy that's
where that comes from
thank you very much we have time for a
few more questions
how do you shear your organoids
yeah great question um and and some of
this does come down to
preference and um you know the cell line
themselves
different organoids like sort of
different treatments
i have had the most success using a 20
gauge
needle blunt needle attached to a 1ml
syringe
but i also know some people who really
just like to use
a pipette tip you know either
a p10 tip on top of a p200 tip or a p200
tip in order to
to share their organoids thank you very
much
now can you keep the plate warm or cold
during dispensing
yeah i might take this one so we have
currently
no active warming or cooling options
for the deck having said that as hillary
explained she pre-warmed the plate
in the incubator before putting it into
the dispense nest
and then because the dispense itself is
so fast
you know about a minute for a 96 well
plate
that time frame does not cause a
significant fluctuation
in the temperature of that plate so as
long as it's
uh placed quickly and removed quickly
there isn't
actually any need uh to have active
control of the
temperature on that plate i did mention
we do have
options to cool the reagents which will
sit on the reagent tray potentially for
longer and we're also working on
temperature control of the syringe
itself
great question all of these questions
are wonderful and i want to thank our
audience again
our next question from an audience
member have you characterized intestinal
organize
and what data or parameters do you use
yeah so we did not characterize the
intestinal organoids in this particular
paper because we were really just
looking
at the response but but we have
in the past and actually there are some
publications on the
corning website where we've done some
intestinal organoid characteristic
characterization um gosh at the top of
my head i know we looked at
mucus production and
lgr5 and
gosh i'm blanking on some of the rest
but um i could
uh if you want to provide your email
address i could send you
the paper we have with all of those
details
thank you so much we have one more
question from our audience
does programming software account for
the dead volume
to put in the reservoirs uh yeah i can
take this one
it absolutely does so our software is
really uh
written with usability in mind so
as a user you would simply
write the dispense volume per well that
you want to achieve
write the number into the software so
you can any uh
number really we're not limited to steps
of 200 nanoliters
um you select the wells that you want to
fit
uh phil and how many syringes you want
to do that and what type of reservoir
you have
and the software calculates
automatically
how much reagent you have to lay out to
the nearest microliter
and that takes into account any dead
volume um so it's really designed to be
simple
the only other parameter as a user you
would have to specify is the plate type
that you're going into
but again being a non-contact suspense
the system is very tolerant of plate
type so
getting getting up and running is really
really easy
i want to thank you ann and thank you
hillary for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we go
sure um first of all i would like to say
thank you for taking the time out of
your busy schedules to listen in today
um
i hope you found today's session
informative uh
hillary and i are available to answer
any
uh questions that you may have i think
the best contact on the sbt lab
tech side is either through the dialogue
which i think will keep open
or discover at sptlabtech.com
hillary um over to you sure
um i guess the one comment that i would
make is that
um you know this is just sort of a proof
of concept of how you could use
the dragonfly for a particular
application
but the other methods of of doing major
gel
3d assays that i described previously
the sandwich and the embedded could also
be used
with the dragonfly so um certainly keep
that in mind
absolutely we're really open to
different uh formats of assay
if you have any particular ideas get in
touch with us
and we'll figure out how we can best
support your application
i want to thank you again and hillary
for your time and for your important
research
and before we go i also want to thank
labrit and our sponsor spt
lab tech for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labrets will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us
until next time stay safe stay healthy
take care
everyone bye